is this part of my training just watch
god look at you
move she never wants to leave her dad's
side i think it's time for you to get
back to basics
it takes time to honor your skills
what do you think it means to be like me
you know
how about how much do you think she
wants to impress her hero
you never come back
[Music]
how old are you when it happened i was
born um
a few years before if you vanish but
i don't have any memories of you
so the wedding was pretty much the first
time i met you
he'd imagine so many different things to
say to you
still can't believe i went with remember
to say i do
i guess things don't always go the way
you plan them
hey everybody it's charlie we got some
new flash footage to break down from
episode two and the most epic
of reverse flash teasers for crisis on
infinite earth
there's a new round of that blast ring
giveaway going on all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on the video i'll name a new
winner at the end of this
so if you re-watch the episode a couple
times you can actually read the text
on nora's version of the future
newspaper from 25 years after
the initial future newspaper in 2024
we've been pouring over it for the last
couple of seasons but what it actually
says
is in the years following the crisis
accounts only grew more contradictory
some eyewitnesses remember dozens of
other heroes present including green
arrow
batwoman and elongated man others
remember heroes
thought lost in time like the atom or
from other worlds like
supergirl some even contend that they
saw reverse flash
leading an army of shadow demons so what
they've actually done there
is retconned their original crisis on
infinite earth that they teased during
the flash pilot that we've been seeing
on the future newspaper for the past
five years on the tv show
flash vanishes in crisis like there's
the batman reference to the queen
industries wayne tech merger at the
bottom
you have the red skies vanish which is a
reference to superman that's something
that the reverse flash
would do to prevent superman from
absorbing yellow sunlight or
supergirl now in this case as they
mentioned so what they've done now is
because they've introduced all these new
characters to the universe they're
actually legit
building towards a crisis on infinite
earth's crossover
in a couple years who knows what they'll
end up changing from the comics it'll be
their tv show version the arrowverse
version of crisis on infinite earths
you also may have spotted the shout out
to psycho pirate who's also a big
character from crisis on
infinite earth it says research is
fractured on roger hayden who is the
psycho pirate character
who claims to remember tonight's events
he said upon his arrest
worlds lived worlds died nothing will
ever be the same
that's a quote taken directly from the
comic book he was actually cursed
to remember all of the events of crisis
whereas it was a big retcon for the
universe because they collapsed the
multiverse
so a lot of the characters didn't
remember the burden of that but he was
forced to remember the terror of
everything
that had happened when they say the
reverse flash is leading an army of
shadow demons
what they're probably referring to is
the shadow demons from dark side war
that were fighting for the anti-monitor
what was basically anti-monitor vs dark
side and the forces of apocalypse
so dark side war was a slightly
different event than crisis
think of crisis more in the comic book
way this is all about barry allen
sacrificing his life to destroy
the anti-monitor's weapon so that he
goes back then and becomes the bolt of
lightning that gave him powers during
season one
nora's big thing now we know is
preventing that from happening whether
or not that's actually possible remains
to be
seen because you know if that's gonna be
her big thing this season i'm gonna find
a way to save my father
that was barry's thing for all of season
one i'm gonna find out who killed my
mother and i'm gonna save her
turns out accomplishing that easier said
than done so it sounds like nora is just
gonna have to come to the same
conclusion
that barry did during season three after
flashpoint i just have to learn to be
okay
with my father barry allen dying part of
the fun of this though is her thinking
that she's smarter
than that that oh i can actually figure
out a way i'm from the future i have all
this advanced technology
there's got to be a way that i can
prevent him from dying so way back
during season one we saw this
they said it was just a teaser like they
were just joking about the batman wayne
tech merger with queen industries yeah
you know maybe we'll get to do that
someday
well now we have the monitor appearing
during this year's crossover
meaning that if they have that character
we probably have an anti-monitor
somewhere in the anti-matter universe
but if you guys spotted it there were a
lot of reverse flash easter eggs during
the episode that i didn't talk about
she talks about a mr miles that was the
curator of the flash museum
that could be the new version of the
reverse flash but like i was talking
about
how they make minor changes to the
timeline and that might give them some
more comic book easter eggs down the
road
like right now nora's had a relatively
lonely
life being an only child kind of a bad
relationship with her mother in the
future
iris so the idea is is that while
they're making changes to the timeline
this season they accidentally change a
couple things
maybe she winds up with a twin brother
in the future but also
their changes in the timeline also
affect the new version of the reverse
flash
so obviously we have the matt lecher
version right now the original eo
part-thon then we have the harrison
wells version
you make changes to the timeline like
they made the joke about eddie getting a
vasectomy during the episode
that also affects what's going on with
reverse flash in the future so that's
also a way for him to come back
looking different because of quote
unquote changes that they make
but really the easiest way to introduce
him is just to have him secretly be
the curator of the flash museum that's
probably the most fanservicy way to
accomplish that and they mention it so
many times i definitely think we'll get
at least a little peek
at the flash museum hopefully in the
hundredth episode but they haven't
revealed anything about that so if we
actually do get that we probably won't
hear about it for a while because right
now they're filming the crossover
episode
stephen amell just dropped a big teaser
he said that they're going to make some
announcements
on thursday so whatever that is i will
totally do a video for it
but part of the fun of next week's
episode is just running barry through
the paces of trying to teach
nora all the different skills that he
learned in the first couple of seasons
like throwing lightning
then she hits him with his giant blast
it's okay i've been hit with lightning
before
the title of the episode is blocked
which is a bit of a play on this metas
powers who literally puts barry
in a block and stops him dead in his
tracks for all you max mercury fans that
have been wondering why we haven't seen
him on the show
but we have mercury labs they have
mercury on the building behind here too
maybe we'll see a version of him at some
point cicada is also supposed to be
coming for this meta and that's how he
crosses paths
with team flash so the picture of him
with the dagger in front of cisco and
then him clutching his hand
might be from episode two this seems
like it'll lead to cisco losing his
powers
we'll see what kind of an arc they give
him in the first part of the season just
because of this big cicada twist
but everybody start freaking out about
reverse flash his secret army of shadow
demons the minions of the anti-monitor
and all this crazy
stuff that they're building up towards
stephen amell has been teasing the
crossover this year more than anyone
else so if he drops any more info bombs
i will totally include it in videos he
actually said that he's going to be the
person to start the crossover so like
the opening scene will be a scene with a
version of oliver queen
i know everybody's freaking out about
james gunn jumping from marvel to dc to
do that suicide squad movie
possibly other big dc movies in the
future if things go well
i'll do a video about that next
explaining what's going on because it
actually involves a lot of changes to
the plot of avengers 4
for the guardians of the galaxy because
of what they did postponing that movie
so that video should be up in the next
couple of hours there's also a whole
bunch of other news that dropped so i'll
post updates in the comments and then on
my twitter feed
all the links for that are in the
description so everybody get hyped it's
going to be awesome
yologamer55 congratulations you're the
giveaway winner for my last big video
please email me on the about page of my
channel so i can get your details
click here for my episode 1 video and
click here for that new carnage venom
trailer thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome
see you guys tonight